[Musique]
elles ont entre 12 et 16 ans elles sont
collégienne et toutes issues de la caste
la plus basse en inde les dalit
en maths le professeur nous a donné
quelques exercices important oui
quelques théories à ok tu me les envoie
par whatsapp ok il y avait des devoirs
d'anglais aussi non non non je prends
pas non
notre école est à 12 km de chez moi je
prends tous les jours le bus pour y
aller et ça me permet de rencontrer des
amis
c'est un moment de discussion avec ma
copine et
j'aime vraiment bien ce moment
à 16 ans qu'annie qu'a fait partie des
1600 fille de l'état de l'uttar pradesh
à être scolarisés dans cette école
l'école par dada par daddy
un projet éducatif hors norme en inde
l'école est gratuite de la maternelle à
la terminale et chaque élève reçoit du
matériel d'étude des uniformes de quoi
payer le transport trois repas par jour
et même des serviettes hygiéniques
car ici tout est pensé pour que canicas
et ses camarades s'épanouissent loin de
leur destinée promise par leur origine
sociale
je viens d'un milieu rural et ma famille
ne peut pas se permettre de me payer des
études et puis dans mon village c'est
compliqué d'étudier car beaucoup de
personnes en l'esprit étroit et
n'envoient pas leurs enfants à l'école
je veux devenir médecin mais je sais
qu'ici je peux réaliser mon rêve
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à l'école canicas sus un cours sur
l'égalité des sexes il faut dire que le
niveau de discrimination et elle en inde
qui conduit souvent au viol et au
meurtre
savez-vous quelque chose sur les
inégalités de sexe
[Musique]
l'inégalité des genres signifie la
discrimination entre deux genres en
particulier dans notre société la
discrimination entre les filles et les
garçons les garçons ont le droit
d'étudier de jouer d'aller à l'école et
de travailler mais pour les filles il ya
beaucoup de discrimination elles ne
peuvent pas sortir pour l'heure actuelle
elles ne peuvent pas aller à l'école les
hommes pensent que les filles ne sont là
que pour les travaux ménagers dans son
cours rina sharma enseigne à ses jeunes
élèves comment se sortir du déterminisme
sexuel et la tâche s'annonce ardue en
inde particulièrement dans les campagnes
naître fille est encore considérée comme
une malédiction
à la maison nos parents nous demande
tout le temps de boire moins de lait
pour en laisser plus un autre frère et
si nous cuisinons quelque chose de bon à
la maison à nos parents nous demandent
aussi d'en manger moins et d'en donner
toujours plus à notre frère
les garçons ont le droit d'hériter des
biens de leurs parents les filles n'ont
pas ce droit
les parents disent toujours peu importe
ce qu'il fait c'est un garçon il n'y
aura jamais de problème
son avenir est assuré par ce que les
biens des parents sont sa propriété mais
l'avenir des filles lui n'est pas du
tout assuré
les parents pensent qu'une fille
trouvera un garçon qu'elle se mariera et
donc qu'elle n'aura pas de problème
l'exercice que je vous donne maintenant
est basé sur l'inégalité des sexes
quelles sont les caractéristiques
biologiques de celle-ci et quels
changements sont dus à l'impact social
[Musique]
pour chaque situation que je vous donne
vous devez dire s'il s'agit d'une
inégalité biologique
dans ce cas vous rester assise
compris s'il s'agit d'une inégalité
sociale alors vous restez debout voilà
ne pas faire d'études
porter une rare
les menstruations
changer les mentalités
changer l'image que les femmes ont
d'elle-même c'est l'une dès missions que
s'est donc fixé l'équipe pédagogique de
l'école
bonjour tout le monde contente de vous
voir tous réunis
nous devons garder une chose à l'esprit
si nous donnons une éducation dans cet
institut il faut que les étudiants
deviennent des personnes positif pour
qu'elle devienne un modèle pour notre
société
si vous donnez 100 roupies un an
imaginez ce que l'homme fort il va faire
la fête et le dépensera dans des petites
choses 10 ultime mais si vous donnez 100
une pièce non seulement elle assurera la
nourriture de la famille mais elle
réussira même à l'école
si on donne aux femmes la possibilité de
s'épanouir la société sera bien meilleur
malheureusement nous sommes dans une
société où il y à des disparités trop
importantes entre les sexes
beaucoup de ces jeunes adolescentes sont
victimes de harcèlement et de violence
sexuelle au sein même de leur famille
l'école dispense donc un cours de
théâtre sur ce thème le but libérer leur
parole sur un sujet tabou
ici une scène entre une fille et son
beau père
[Musique]
perd 30 ans tu es bon tu as dû te pose
lui s'y
arrête de me prendre les mains n'est pas
moi tu as peur s'il te plaît laisse-moi
parties qu'elles parlent à personne ne
soit au courant je suis comme ta fille
tu es mon père mais arrête
et vient pas ce nom sur un
harcèlement et violence sexuelle en inde
les jeunes filles dalit font face à des
obstacles de taille pour exister mais ce
qui les empêche d'avoir accès à
l'éducation
ce sont surtout les mariages forcés
quand les parents arrange le mariage de
leur fille sans permission
et que la fille ne veut pas se marier
alors elle nous fait part de son
problème parfois cette une de ses amies
qui nous le dit
dans ce cas je me rends dans la famille
pour rencontrer des pareils est planté
[Musique]
on
ici les castes régissent la vie de
centaines de millions de personnes
[Musique]
ce jour là c'est le professeur rend
visite à la famille d'une élève de
terminale absente de l'école depuis
plusieurs mois
bonjour
comment allez vous
la mère de cette jeune fille de 16 ans
est gravement malade et cherche à marier
sa fille au plus vite
je voudrais vous dire que vous n'avez
pas besoin de préparer son mariage
laissez-la continuer ses études elle
vous aidera le matin et le soir pour des
travaux ménagers sa jeune soeur aussi
pourra vous aider mais n'arrêtaient pas
les études votre corps
vous en êtes sûr d'accord
sa mère et son père ne lui permettait
plus d'aller à l'école vous voyez la
mère est malade et elle est au lit alors
sa fille doit faire le ménage et
s'occuper de toute la maison
deuxième chose
leurs conditions économiques sont
vraiment mauvaises ses frères aînés la
pousse à se marier mais elle est bien
trop jeune pour cela mais
je suis vraiment heureuse parce que sa
mère est d'accord avec moi et elle m'a
promis que sa fille y retournera à
l'école à partir de demain
je fais cela pour rendre ces jeunes
filles meilleur pour qu'ils aient un
avenir et c'est un rêve pour moi d'y
parvenir
celle que l'on appelait autrefois les
intouchables subissent donc un double
handicap celui d'être né fille est dans
une caste inférieure
nous retrouvons canicas dans le village
de bad pourra à 12 km de son école ou et
le petit bol rend le s'il te plaît
comme ça un petit morceau
les enfants mènent à faire la cuisine
autrement si j'étais seul je n'aurais
pas le temps de tout faire
je dois travailler toute la journée à la
maison parfois on les sent même le curé
mambé mais
j'ai trop de choses à faire
maman n'est souhaitée dans une tasse il
te plaît
à voir scolarisés canicas est une fierté
pour sa mère
mes parents ne m'ont pas permis
d'étudier nous voulons donc que notre
fille réussisse à la ve
j'ai trois filles et aucun fils et
pourtant je suis si fier
son père est cardiaque et moi je souffre
également de michael janyk a fait de
bonnes études elle pourra se débrouiller
seuls à l'avenir et elles pourraient
occuper de ces jeunes soeurs si quelque
chose nous arrive et
[Musique]
je suis vraiment un homme peau je n'ai
pas beaucoup d'argent
heureusement je n'ai pas à payer la
scolarité de camille qu'à
l'administration de l'école de
ma fille va pouvoir avancer dans la vie
pourtant et malgré les efforts seuls 30%
des femmes indiennes travail
d'aujourd'hui
en plus d'apprendre l'informatique
l'anglais et les mathématiques
ces jeunes élèves apprennent à s'armer
dans une société structurée par le
patriarcat
pour éviter qu'elles ne quittent
prématurément cette école la directrice
leur offre 10 roupies par jour 60
centimes d'euros en plus des trois repas
quotidiens
grâce à ce système les élèves de l'école
par dada par l'adie ont un taux de
présence de 85%
bien plus que les autres écoles de
l'uttar pradesh